so we're gonna do a spoiler interview so
you guys are free and clear to say
whatever you want we're gonna run it
after the fact one of it so given that I
don't really like asking generic
questions but because we're talking
spoilers right now I am curious what was
the scene that you found the most
difficult to shoot whether it was
something involving SIDS abilities or
maybe it was just a challenging
emotional scene we differ for both of us
how was your heist the highest one was
great for me though the hardest scene to
shoot wasn't really because of you know
it being super emotional we just had
such great oh yeah yeah when Whittaker
comes in with a gun scrapers you guys
you suck really what it was that was the
first time that we were all in a scene
so it was a little later on in the
process so we were all really friendly
at this point and we're all this is the
first time we're all in a scene together
so we were just we couldn't stop it was
the hardest thing because we could not
stop laughing and so Jonathan actually
came in at some points and was like hey
he was saying Whittaker was like you
know you can improv now and you know and
we all it's all sudden the lines we're
not ready for it wait what's going on
but instead of being like mortified we
just started laughing or the Jonathan
video of it there's a video of us just
literally crying laughing off camera
yeah yeah you guys make me so happy
just between talking to the two of you
and and also Sofia and white I'm sure
they're awesome seems like a great
ensemble and I think it kind of enhances
the material a little too absolutely I
mean it's it's fun when it feels like
you're working with your family yeah I
mean and that's pretty much what it felt
like it by the end of it's great that
you have such a like pretty small cast
to you so yeah you know we're always in
each other's business and hanging
that's thinking of becoming a family
though I'm wondering how that ending
speech was for you especially when you
have to deliver something like that
right to Sofia's face is that a tough
things kind of get get yourself going
for I'm sure you I was I look like a bit
of a lunatic that day I was just I'm
we're all like well I know Sophia and I
were like and then rich was like you're
like I that was yeah I I just remember
kind of pacing back and forth and
normally I would screw around with Wyatt
a lot and there was a moment where I was
like I'm sorry buddy but you gotta you
gotta leave me alone on this one
which he would because he's you know the
consummate professional he was like you
absolutely do your thing but it was um
there's this weird thing where you can
kind of remove yourself and be able to
look at it objectively and it's I know
it's not me saying this to Sofia so when
you when you can take that pressure off
of yourself you can really just twist
the knife and I'm get into it but that
scene only works if you do treat it as
seriously as it is yeah I'm such a
sucker this is why I can't be an actor I
would lose sleep over that oh I was so I
was I was excited for it I was really I
can hear that for weeks in advance I
made sure I knew it worked like
word-for-word before I was even close to
shooting it so what about some cuz I'm a
big hard junkie and when you show me an
end scene like that I gotta know about
all the movie magic that happens behind
this Oh what do you have to do on set to
get all the layers of that done so first
and foremost we just focused on just the
speech and the delivery and the -
Sophia's mind you I think you both took
two takes each to be that into it you
got it on the first one I think it was
Gary but it was unbelievable to watch
where it's like just they didn't they
didn't need to wrap up it was like one
run-through on their coverage and they
were just like mortified my house is
amazing so it made my job a lot easier
because when you can feed off those
reactions anyway fast-forwarding so we
really focused on that the pump punching
why it was one of my favorite parts of
the entire shoot we had the block like
oh that was so great yes Wow
oh because we were looking
order that seems like yeah you get to
punch me but when it got to that
basically they had constructed this
device where it was essentially this
giant blood balloon on a stick and they
matched it to my height so what I would
do whenever I would finish what I was
saying I would just kind of like jerk
and and fall onto a mat and they also
did a 3d scan of my head so there's like
this three layered thing essentially
where when I fall off camera they have
this blood bag go and then there was
also a dummy of me decapitated which was
really really st. dimensions it was
really here you know Dina was there like
she like walks up to it actually
oh yes sir hello my girl what funny
tidbits it was out of the whole cast all
of the extras no blood on me I was the
only one I don't know how they teamed
that all oh it was one banthus like
little crane holding up the dummy it was
so many moving parts just to get
everything onto that one frame yeah and
everyone's a little bit very very well
that is one thing that had me a little
curious though I mean it's more like
blocking than anything but what do you
think was going through her head that
she got that close I don't think she was
I think she was so confused it was such
shock and confusion that she almost
didn't it was I mean Dina has this
nature about her where she's so giving
so loving and I think she sees Brad here
on the floor her immediate jerk and gut
reaction is to walk up to it and
investigate but in her head she's like
oh my gosh no it's her nature to go up
in you what's wrong
like what do you need but in her head
she's like shocked confused very not
okay I hope they lean into that
season two because that was an
interesting thing to like go back and
track to just like everybody's body
language immediately after something
like that happens it's very knows
through the extras - yeah where they
were so invested with us man yeah that
when it it looked like such a genuine
reacted because I remember watching and
hearing the scream and it was so um it
was so uncomfortable I remember right
after watching the scene where everyone
is running through the hallway that -
yeah that was so that reminded me of
when I first saw Carrie and I was like
and I also I did carry the musical and
so I wanna yeah and so I had that same
flashback to like feeling that like
grave like cloud and just being like oh
my gosh this is a huge shift in this
town yeah is about like something it's
coming playing Carrie the musical where
who did you play and Carrie the my gosh
I think I actually made up her name
because I was one of the like girls okay
okay I got it so I get it I'm hiding
junkie so that excites not too much one
last question for you I'm curious just
of Dena's mind frame pre kissed and post
kiss because it's a very interesting
journey to track especially because the
assumptions I made about her during the
kiss were not where she ended up so for
you're talking about her and sit yeah
just just playing with that kind of mind
frame hmm so I think before that I mean
she's with Brad and I think what she
really wants is validation and
acceptance and she kind of finds it in
Brad and not necessarily because Brad is
giving her the comfort II needs but the
comfort she gets from being with Brad
and having that status and so she was
kind of filling in that void for herself
with that kind of comfort of validation
and then she kind of found an authentic
validation after she realized she might
sort of have feelings for Sid and was
like wow this actually feels way better
and and that was the kind of comfort
that she needed all along
so I think her mindset was really just
realizing what truly caring for someone
is and you know having emotions for
someone and just feeling comfortable in
a situation you're in because you're not
because you're about you feel validated